hey everyone
my name is brandon aker and this is part
two
of a video i made all about how to
choose a
classical guitar if you missed part one
you can actually head to my youtube
channel by checking out the link in the
description
part one was all about sort of the
things that i consider to be
the things you need to know before you
head to a guitar shop
uh things like you know what's the
difference between
spruce and cedar soundboards
what are the different sizes of guitars
available and
you know what's kind of the price range
of different classical guitars
so if you missed that go ahead to
my youtube channel and check that out
but today in part two
we're going to be a bit more pragmatic
and the goal is to talk about
what to do when you get in the guitar
shop and someone says hey here's a
really pricey guitar
and they put it in your hands you know
what do you do what should you play how
do you test it out
to find out if this is a good instrument
or maybe maybe the better way to say
that
is is this the right instrument for you
so
we'll explore all of that today in
choosing a guitar part two
so let's say that today is the exciting
day that you're going to head to the
guitar shop
and maybe even make a purchase my first
tip
is if you have a classical guitar
already that you play
bring it with you so you can a and b it
with the other instruments
it's a weird you know sometimes i think
i really know my instrument i've put in
so many hundreds and maybe
thousands of hours on it but when we get
there we play another instrument we can
sort of you know forget
what our instrument felt like in the
first place okay so let's say you made
it to the guitar shop
you brought your guitar with you and
maybe you can select a few instruments
that are
you know within your price range and
you're ready to try some
the question is what should you do you
know what should you play on them and
what are you looking for
so my main goal today is to equip you
with
some goals basically a couple things to
look for in each instrument
and the goal is not to find the best
instrument necessarily it's to find the
instrument that's right for you
because there's some objective factors
here and some subjective
that we're going to get into now i want
to start by stating what i actually
believe to be the real goal
of an instrument and that is to be a
really good
tool and i know that that part doesn't
sound so poetic but maybe the next one
does here's how i think the process
should work
you start with a musical conception in
your mind a conception of how the piece
goes of how you like to play it
of you know what tone you would like
when dynamics
touch everything then
that mental conception has to be
filtered through a tool an instrument
unless you're singing
and then it becomes sound right and
we want that process to be as seamless
as possible and a good instrument a good
tool
just simply mediates that process and
the problem is if you don't have a good
instrument
it inhibits the musical conceptions in
your mind
and then they don't make it to the other
end right
so what we really want in a guitar is
a tool which will assist that flowy
process
from mental conception to sound in in
the smoothest way
possible and a good guitar will assist
that process
a great guitar will enhance that process
it's kind of a magical thing sometimes i
pick up a guitar
which is just you know something there's
something special about it
and whatever my musical conception was
it is now
better when it's filtered through the
wonders
of that instrument so i want to start by
saying
that's our real goal find a guitar which
when you play it
enhances your musical goals that would
be
the ideal all right and in case that was
all too
abstract and poetic for you let's get a
bit more
pragmatic here you have the guitar in
your hands
what specific things can you look for on
an instrument to determine whether or
not
it is a good quality instrument for you
for me the
first thing is how is the ease of
playing or the playability you could say
and i think the most important factor
that determines the playability
could be the action and an action on a
guitar
means the height of the strings above
the fretboard
above the frets you could say and that's
why
it's very important i think to actually
bring a ruler
with you or something that can measure
millimeters
bring it with you when you're going to
try a guitar and what you do is
you take the millimeter side and you go
to the 12th fret
and on the 12th fret you put the ruler
and
what you do is you measure from the top
of the fret to the underside
of the first string and that distance
should be something like
three to three and a half millimeters
it could be around that but if it's
higher than
five or five or higher that's a pretty
high action and you might
have a really hard time pushing the
strings down
every time you have to fret a note you
would oh
and that gets pretty exhausting really
fast and it's going to fight
all of your musical ideas so be careful
of a guitar with
with a super high action you can also
measure
the action on the bass side which is
usually a little bit higher than the
treble side
and the same thing you put the ruler at
the 12th fret
on top of the 12th fret and you measure
to the underside of the string
it should be something like 3.5 to 4
millimeters
and again around that but too high
is a problem and in fact too low is a
problem
because then all your frets might be
buzzy
and that's also its own issue all right
here's another
test you can do to measure an action and
this one you just need your fingers
so what you do is you push down on the
third fret with your index finger
on your right hand if you're right
handed and then what you do is
we're going to push the string down
into the first fret and
what we're doing here is we're testing
to see how much clearance is there
between the first fret and then the
string there should be little to none
and you try you know the fifth string
the fourth string
all the way down and if there's a lot of
clearance if you have to really
push the string far to touch the fret
that's also a problem it probably means
that the nut this white piece here
is too tall now it is true that the nut
and the saddle this white piece over
here
can both be changed a bit in size to
meet your preferences
but if you pick up an instrument and we
have some serious
you know height here or some serious
height here
it's not a great place to start then a
nice idea would be to
simply play something like a chromatic
scale
and what we're doing here is we're
listening
are there buzzy spots on the guitar
right
and you can really push with rest
strokes
and find out if there's anything buzzy
all the way up and play every every fret
now i would say be careful here
especially if you're not
very experienced remember that even a
good guitar will buzz
if you play in the wrong side of the
fret so if we play on the left side of a
fret i can make every
every note buzz
[Music]
painful i know sorry so play on the
right side of the fret
never on top but just to the left of
each fret and you'll get a perfect
clean note
[Music]
now so we're going to be listening for
buzzes and seeing if there are points on
the instrument
which have some pretty painful rattling
buzzy sounds another thing to pay
attention to would be
the resonance of each instrument you
play
so the resonance basically means how
much does the instrument vibrate
right some instruments when you play
them
you can feel the whole instrument
vibrating against your chest and it
seems like sound is just
you know pushing out of this instrument
and other instruments in comparison can
sound
kind of dead and you pick up another
guitar
and it's louder this is a trick i showed
you in the last
video in part one where you dampen the
top of the instrument so it can't
vibrate
and therefore resonate as much right so
some guitars will seem more
dead and some others will seem more
resonant
another factor is the sustain of an
instrument right
so you could simply pluck one note and
just see
how long does it last
[Music]
now of course a guitar is a decaying
instrument so the sound does
die away pretty quickly all together but
you'll find a huge level of discrepancy
between each guitar
and even the string material can really
having a big impact
on how much sustain each guitar has as
an example let's just listen to the same
note
played on two guitars by the same maker
so here's the high e
and it's gone okay let's try the other
one this is a cedar top
so that one felt like it had more
sustain to me
i'd recommend you also pay attention to
the overall frequency balance
of the instrument you know if we think
just in terms of
base mids and highs kind of like a car
stereo
you'll find that each guitar has a
different balance of
those frequencies um so let's let's hear
something on a spruce top guitar and
then a cedar top
and maybe let's we'll listen for just
the base and to see if there's a
difference between the two
and now let's try the cedar again
[Music]
so it seems quite a lot different i
would say that this guitar
seems more bassy and you might notice
the piece that i selected
on purpose really intensified the bass
range
of the instrument so i could hear the
difference you could do the same thing
for the mid and the treble
a good song for the trouble
like to draw by barrios this is also a
good piece
to listen for the sustain on the on the
really high frets
another thing i look for in each
instrument is sort of its own specific
uh tonal bandwidth you could say uh
meaning that each instrument sits in its
own little bandwidth of all the possible
frequencies
uh it has a range you know what are the
brightest sounds that instrument can
make and what are the darkest sounds
it can make and you'll find that each
guitar sits in its own
its own little bandwidth of the sounds
it can create
so you could you could experiment on
each instrument what are the darkest
sounds i could make
playing fairy tale
and what are the brightest sounds i can
make playing very ponticello
and so that kind of lays out the
possibilities of timbre on on that
guitar and you'll find out that it
really
changes on each instrument another thing
that i tend to notice sort of right away
is the thickness of the neck you know
from
top to back and some guitars have
a super skinny neck so there's almost no
distance you know between the fretboard
and the back
and i find that some feel kind of like a
tree trunk
in my hand and i'm a big fan of thinner
necks
but i know some people who like the
feeling of a thicker neck so i think it
really is preferential
but it's something that i really would
pay attention to all right
so we've covered quite a lot of ground
here what you should feel for
what you should listen for and even what
you should measure
on the instrument and if you do all
those things i think you'll find out
that each guitar
has its own personality its own blend of
all of those parameters
we discussed which makes it a unique
instrument
right and here's kind of where
the the magic comes in what's the best
guitar
is it the most expensive one not
necessarily you want to get the one that
speaks to you
and actually this is where subjective
preference comes in
so do you like the darker sounds or do
you like
the the low uh action or the thick neck
or the thin neck or the super resonant
guitar
or the more intimate sounding guitar
these are preferential things and i have
colleagues who
we think very differently about what
tool we'd like
but in the end remember where we started
today it's all about
your own musical conception which is
unique to you right your own personal
musical choices
that you want to make into real sounds
and that means that you need the tool
the right tool for the job
which is different than your friend's
tool for the job right
and so i think if we use those all these
different tests we talked about today
when trying an instrument out i think in
the end find the instrument that calls
out to you and that really makes you
want to play it
that if you brought it home it would
just be calling out to you to play it
and you think you would practice more
and would enjoy the process of music
making
and that's really the guitar that you
should get
all right well that's it for today i
really hope that you found this to be
beneficial
if you missed part one or are interested
in what else is on my youtube channel
i'd encourage you to go check that out i
have other videos
doing guitar tips but also a series i
call
introducing which is a series in which i
show you all sorts of cool and rare
instruments from the past
not just classical guitar but also loot
baroque tar
theorbo and and more and lastly today i
wanted to mention that
if you are interested in learning guitar
i have actually just opened up an online
music school with my wife
called arpeggiato and if you go to
arpeggiato.com
you'll find a lot of different teachers
in a variety of different
plucked instruments and i'd encourage
you to check that out if you're
interested
in perhaps doing some online lessons
okay
thanks for watching take care
[Music]
and now let's try the cedar again